start off with jeff bezos why he's loved
so much is that okay with you let's go
to page three
jeff bezos we were watching it live last
time he went into space
came back down when he landed
he did a couple different things one uh
he gave
jeff bezos says blue origin has sold
nearly 100 million dollars worth of
tickets for future tourist trips
to space business insider blue origin
officially open ticket sales in the
morning before bezos flight
and in his post-flight press conference
bezos said the company
was approaching a hundred million
dollars in private sales already if not
clear
it's not clear if the company sold any
private tickets before it officially
opened sales on tuesdays
tuesday bezos and or blue origin didn't
disclose seats
prices uh for the journey which traveled
62 miles above the earth's surface a
seat next to bezos
on new shepard went for 28 million in
the company's auction and the winner
pulled out due to shifting scheduling
scheduling conflicts and oliver damon
the 180 took the place instead of him so
the tickets for virgin galactic
uh on the edge of space is 250 000 and
includes a spacesuit so now
a couple of things before we go through
this obviously we saw the new york times
story with pesos
bezos thanks amazon workers and
customers
for his vast wealth prompting backlash
from
aoc and many others he came up there and
says if it wasn't for you i wouldn't be
able to travel out here
i also want to thank every amazon
employee and every amazon customer
because you
you guys paid for all of this his
comments prompted swift critical
reactions including from a member of the
house representative
who serves on tax writing ways and means
in committee space travel isn't a
tax-free holiday for the wealthy
says the representative earl bluemon
bloom number
from oregon we pay taxes on plane
tickets billionaires flying into space
producing no scientific value
should do the same and then some so i
think the opening question for all of
you would be the following
why does bezos get as much hate as he he
lands he gives a hundred million dollars
to van jones
okay he gives a hundred million dollars
to the ship jose andres
he does all this stuff he still gets a
lot of hate why do you think that is
because you have because what ends up
happening is that people are
people are haters by nature right they
don't like people doing better than them
first of all
and if they can't get a piece of the pie
then they even they even get more mad
right so uh but i will tell you i'm
gonna give you my my point of view real
quick on this pat
um i was having this conversation with a
buddy of mine in bakersfield not too
long ago
and uh he he was talking about bezos not
in a bad way but he was you know saying
that he was
excessively rich and i said you know how
much time bazels gave back to your life
and he says what do you mean explain it
to me this is very simple you place an
order right now you get it tomorrow the
next day
you're saving a trip to the store you
could possibly get an accident
you get to spend more time at home with
your kids you can actually help them
with their homework
you don't have to do these these you
don't have to do all these uh daily
activities
as much because you can literally buy
everything on amazon he facilitated your
life
at a cheap price if the man gets rich
doing it that's america
it's it's it's home of the free land of
the brave and uh opportunity for all i'm
not opportunity until you think it was
too much taking advantage of yeah right
so the reality is i don't care how rich
the guy gets because at the end of the
day
because of him i'm able to order stuff
that comes to my door
it avoids me a trip it avoids me time it
saves me time it saves me money
and i can do things that are more
important to me than going to walmart to
pick up some freaking
toilet paper or whatever it is that i
need milk or whatever the case that i do
why do
anybody have a different very great
argument right there any other reason
why you think he gets as much
hate as he gets that's actually i mean
it's a legitimate question because you
start to see like all this hate that's
come towards bezos and obviously
by the way just so you know it's it's
left and the right it's not like the
hate is only from one side he's getting
it from both sides why is that
i think that's a a good q a good
question obviously we all grew up
watching superman and he's been compared
to lex luthor the bald guy
you know what's he up to he's evil don't
return from space we don't want you back
here it's like
let me just tell you something i haven't
had a car in 10 years i
if i don't have to leave my apartment i
won't i order amazon for everything like
the other day i wanted
something for my cats yeah my said my
cats i just ordered it boom it came the
next day
you're absolutely right i think no
matter you said people are haters by
nature i'm wondering why that is like i
think a lot of it has to do with ego
right like the ego is not amigos why do
you think but it was the beginning of
time though
why did why did king kill label he was
jealous of them it's in our dna as
humans regardless of race
i mean the first brothers in the world
one killed the other i think it's a
little bit different because i really
don't like jeff bezos and the reason
okay so yeah that's good so the reason
why is
the system that we keep talking about is
broken like you know the corporatist
which isn't capitalist it's corporatist
right the system that we have
he exploits every single loophole
possible
he does it publicly he does it in one
second explain that okay
so the the fact that this guy is able to
accumulate the wealth that he has right
which which
nobody in the beginning is going to say
wow don't accumulate wealth nobody at
this table
and as as a staunch free market guy
myself if you don't like amazon
feel free to buy anything else there's
there's many other things you can
absolutely
but what he does and and he has a team
and it's smart to work within the system
but he exploits the system
through and through he goes into new
locations he makes sure that he gets the
best tax
uh uh situation possible in the system
he has
different uh locations so we're mad at
him because he's going to negotiate no
no i
see the thing is i'm not mad at him no
no no i'm just saying so i think what
happens this is what i'm trying to say i
think what happens
is that he publicly represents
everything wrong with our government in
our system
but in what sense because he he exposes
it is what i'm saying i know
right now but he's playing by the way is
he doing anything illegal no perfect
he's doing anything illegal he even says
the people that that have a problem with
me are mostly right that was actually
him
what i'm specifically talking about okay
he got 10 billion dollars
during an economic recession after a
pandemic to go play
you know just the tip with the outer
atmosphere you know what i'm saying like
he got in a big veiny
space rocket and went out there's gerard
can't get the dick out of his mind
can't get that johnson out of his mind
he can't get it out of my mouth adam but
the
the thing is he's had it before the
thing is
he gets 10 billion dollars right and the
first thing that that the government
says
when he goes to outer space the first
thing that they say is where's our cut
we tax you when you we tax normal people
when whoa time out
you shouldn't be taxing us either you
don't you don't get to give 13 billion
dollars to american airlines for them to
never take off on time
you know so so the fact that the
government the first thing that they did
when they got back
was where's our cut right it wasn't
that we gave you 10 billion dollars that
should have been reallocated to people
who really really need it
after being held political hostage for
18 months you see what i'm saying
no i'm not mad at bezos for taking the
money i'm not mad at anybody we talked
about this a couple weeks ago i'm not
mad at anybody that takes government
money right now
because if the government's going to
hand it out to their boys you get yours
if you play by their rules that they
refuse to play by
you're not noble you're assassination go
forward because
it's something that comes to mind it's
like why are all these ultra
tech billionaires yeah the jack dorsey's
of the world
the bezos of the world the luxembourg
why do they always lean
left why are they democrats is it fair
to say that they mostly kind of vote
step in uh yeah because because of
regulation
but progressive policies help them
help exactly them correct open borders
help exactly
it doesn't it just drops the weight of
people exactly right yeah they talk
about taxes right that's beneficial
it says they're not worried about taxes
bro they're worried about regulation let
me play ball is that right
uh they're they're in uh by the way anas
just said he gave 20 bucks as it's
because the workers he treats workers
like crap amazon workers deserves
30 hours uh plus he's greedy unionist to
the
tg answer the answer it's the workers
who did it that's him the other one is
it's not ego
this is from little panda club he says
it's not ego people project
outwards because they are afraid to
assess inwards exploitation is not
illegal it might be unethical and
immoral okay
so just real quick on that bezos has
spoken about that
and he says look i he basically
optimized the work
hour the work week within the current
employment laws
so he again is exploiting the rule of
law people are saying it's unethical to
have the people work that way and his
thing is okay when the laws change i'll
change it
because don't change so it's the perfect
thing and it's like you said
it's the difference between being legal
and unethical so okay
but here's a question to you okay
perfect and by the way i'm not
disagreeing with you but my question to
you is whose fault is it the
government's or his
okay well you it's a blurry line who
pays for the government well
it's not a he didn't pay for the
government before he got into before he
created amazon
so all those laws and rules and
regulations were set before he became
who he is today
if he was truly the progressive that he
says he is if he was truly this
for the people person right i don't know
if he claims
to be something progressive though but
so he's exploiting
people's empathy you know who also does
that people you know you know this is
this is eerily similar to someone who
used those exact same rhetoric
montgomery burns no
donald trump would say i just the the
system is i donate to
republicans democrats i play within the
rules if you don't like it
only i can fix it it sounds like you
drop bezos
and you don't like trump i didn't say i
like bezos i like amazon i like amazon i
don't care i like amazon i don't care
it's not like i'm a bezos fan so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]